NARRATOR: The China Seas.
Ringed by the countries
of southeast Asia,
these are some of the
most fiercely contested
waters on earth.
Beneath the waves,
the shattered remains
of epic battles.
JAMES: It's as if you took
hundreds of ships and put
them through a blender.
NARRATOR:
Mysterious treasures, and
technological wonders all
hidden from view...
until now.
Imagine if we could
empty the oceans, letting
the water drain away to
reveal the secrets
of the sea floor.
Now, we can.
Using the latest
underwater scanning technology,
piercing the deep oceans
and turning accurate
data into 3D images.
How did America defeat
the biggest battleship
of World War II?
JAMES: It was huge.
It was powerful, it was fast.
For the Americans
facing it, it was a
brute of a battleship.
NARRATOR: What's the
truth behind the strange
disappearance of the
mightiest invasion force
of ancient times?
ERIC: One of the biggest
disasters in the history
of maritime warfare.
NARRATOR: And how do you
protect the Worldwide Web
from the perils of nature?
To compete or collaborate?
Trade or invade?
These twin human
instincts have defined the
China Seas for centuries.
As these turbulent waters
begin to drain away,
140 miles south of Japan, they
reveal a top-secret battleship.
The biggest ever put to sea.
What were its secrets?
And why couldn't they save
the lives of 3,000 men?
October 1944,
two giant warships sail
towards the biggest
naval battle in history.
The mighty Yamato and
its twin, Musashi.
-The size of the Yamato
is, is breathtaking.
The Yamato and
its sister ship, Musashi,
were by far the biggest
battleships ever built.
NARRATOR: Almost
900 feet long,
127 feet wide,
these super battleships
dwarf their opponents.
Their hulls are protected
by an incredible
16 inches of armor plate.
And every part of them
bristles with weapons.
On the bow, two giant turrets.
Then over 100 smaller guns.
Before a third turret.
They are the biggest
floating fortresses
ever put to sea.
As the flagship of
the Imperial Japanese Navy,
Yamato carries the seal
of the Emperor himself.
A golden chrysanthemum.
JAMES: Yamato comes from the
term Yamato-Damashii, which is
the national spirit of Japan.
It was literally the
embodiment of Japan itself.
NARRATOR: Yamato isn't just
big, it's also top secret.
ERIC: The Japanese took
enormous measures to keep the
Yamato secret from foreign
navies, even to the extent of,
of, of putting up a building
so that western naval attaches
could not see the ship
under construction.
NARRATOR: Even Yamato's
commanding officers
aren't told its true size.
Its secrets, whatever
they may be, are to be
protected at all cost.
MARK: And they were
successful in this because
for the entire war,
the Americans had no
idea of the ship's true
size or the size of the
guns that she carried.
NARRATOR: Japan's secret
battleships are put to the
test in one of the biggest
naval battles of World War II.
Three years after
Japan bombs Pearl Harbor,
the Pacific War is
about to reach its peak.
Advancing towards Japan,
US and Australian forces
launch an invasion
of the Philippines.
Yamato and Musashi
lead the Japanese fleet
as it tries to stop the
allies in their tracks.
The Battle of Leyte Gulf in
October 1944 is the biggest
naval fight in history.
An epic slugfest of 300 ships.
ERIC: Leyte Gulf
was the last chance the
Japanese fleet had to stop
the American advance.
NARRATOR: Yamato
draws first blood.
Its big guns batter
the US carrier Gambier Bay,
sending it to the sea floor.
The Allies
respond with cannons,
torpedoes and aircraft.
A massive barrage of
firepower that destroys
26 Japanese ships...
and damages dozens more.
MARK: It marked the end
of the Japanese Navy as an
effective fighting force.
NARRATOR: Yamato is hit...
but is saved by its
immensely strong armor.
Musashi isn't so lucky.
It sinks under
an onslaught of American
bombs and torpedoes,
and 1,000
crew members are killed.
On the brink of defeat,
the Japanese now resort to
a new and shocking tactic.
They call it kamikaze.
JAMES: Thousands of young
men dive their aircraft onto
the decks of enemy ships.
NARRATOR: They believe
that their self-sacrifice
will save Japan.
But it's not enough to
hold back the US forces.
After their victory at
Leyte Gulf, the Americans
reached Japan's doorstep,
the outlying
islands of Okinawa.
Japan sends Yamato
into battle once again.
On the 7th of April 1945,
it powers towards
its destiny.
With orders to
intercept the invaders
and fight to the death.
The ultimate kamikaze mission.
JAMES: This huge ship,
this ultimate battleship,
is sent on a one-way
mission to turn itself
into a giant gun battery
to try to keep the
American ships away.
NARRATOR: But Yamato
never makes it to Okinawa.
The Americans launch a
surprise attack, with
overwhelming force.
The super battleship's size
and incredible strength
can't save it this time.
Two hours after
the first wave of bombs,
the flagship of the
Imperial Japanese Navy
plunges below the waves.
So, what were Yamato's
secrets and why couldn't
they save the ship?
Half a century later,
French and Japanese
wreck explorers set
out to unlock the mystery.
Sonar readings confirm
wreckage on the seabed
140 miles south of Japan.
But the ghostly shadow
gives little away.
They deploy a submarine.
As it descends into
the darkness, its lights
pick out a strange shape.
NARRATOR: Could these giant
twisted pieces of metal
really belong to Yamato?
They search for proof.
-Yes.
JAMES: As one who in the world
shipwreck community watched
those first images come back,
it was striking and powerful.
NARRATOR: Amongst
the scattered debris...
reminders of the fate of
the ship's 3,000 man crew.
Yamato is Japan's
worst naval tragedy.
Using detailed sonar
data from this expedition,
along with the latest
computer imaging technology,
it's possible to drain the
water from the China Seas,
to reveal one of the biggest
wreck sites in the world.
And finally, discover
the secrets of Yamato.
First, the Emperor's seal
comes clearly into view.
Then, its gigantic
propellers,
each stretching
20 feet across.
And shockingly, the final
agonies of this mammoth
warship are laid bare.
It is completely ripped apart.
JAMES: The violent death
of Yamato and the sprawled
corpse of the battleship,
makes for a compelling image
because the ship was literally
broken apart into chunks,
and that's what you
see on the bottom.
NARRATOR: So, what is
Yamato's big secret?
Experts scour the site to
appreciate its sheer scale.
And the incredible thickness
of its armored hull.
But they believe there's
something else still hidden,
and to see it means draining
not only the ocean,
but the seabed itself.
To reveal these.
When Yamato was built,
the Allies assumed it was
fitted with 15-inch cannons,
common on battleships
of the time.
But they were wrong.
Yamato's
cannons are actually
18 inches, the biggest and
most powerful ever
fitted to a warship.
Each can fire a shell
the weight of a car,
for almost 30 miles.
JAMES: To have 18-inch
guns on a battleship,
means not only do you have
bigger guns than other folks,
you have guns that
can shoot farther, you
have guns that can shoot
with more punch.
So, it's, it's a
tremendous tactical advantage
for the Japanese in the
age of the battleship.
NARRATOR: Kazushi
Hiro, a Naval Signalman
who served on Yamato,
recalls their
enormous firepower.
KAZUSHI: The sound
was very loud.
It felt as if many
thunderbolts struck
the ship all at once.
NARRATOR:
But if Yamato had the most
powerful guns on water,
why didn't it put
up more of a fight?
NARRATOR: The drained
wreck of the world's
biggest battleship reveals
dramatic details
of its final battle.
Scattered all around,
hundreds of shell casings
from Yamato's own guns.
But a closer look
reveals they're not
from its giant cannons.
Many of these casings are
from a much smaller weapon.
Yamato's cannons are designed
to destroy other battleships
but are of little use against
fast moving attack aircraft.
It defends itself with
much smaller 25-millimeter
guns that fire shells
just over an inch in diameter.
But these guns have a problem.
ERIC: Unlike British
and American capital ships,
which were armed with
40-millimeter weapons,
the Japanese had
nothing like that.
They moved straight from
a five-inch anti-aircraft
gun, to a 25-millimeter
anti-aircraft gun, and
this made Yamato vulnerable
to torpedo bomber attack.
It was a very mediocre
weapon, slow elevation,
slow rate of fire.
And it had a lot
of vibrations, so it
was very inaccurate.
NARRATOR: Yamato's
underperforming anti-aircraft
guns are no match for an
opponent she was never
designed to fight.
Swarms of fast moving
attack planes, carrying
bombs and torpedoes,
launched from the latest
US aircraft carriers.
Each of these holes marks
a successful strike.
Enough to cripple Yamato.
But the drained remains
of this sunken giant
reveal another mystery.
Its 16-inch armor is
shredded like tin foil,
and its massive
hull is blown in half.
No bomb or torpedo
could have done that.
Could it be that Yamato
was ultimately destroyed
by her own secret weapon?
Amongst the scattered
debris lies the heart of the
ship's fearsome firepower.
This hole is where the forward
18-inch gun turret used
to sit and where shells and
propellant were stored
in magazines before being
fed to the cannons above.
-This is a potentially very
vulnerable part of the ship.
If fire is introduced
into the magazine,
it has the potential to
destroy the entire ship.
NARRATOR: A clue
to Yamato's fate comes
from this rare footage.
It shows a torpedoed
British World War II
battleship, HMS Barham,
slowly sinking as
it takes on water.
As the ship capsizes,
shells begin to tumble from
the magazine racks inside.
800 men die.
The drained wreck of Yamato
shows how the blast that
rips it apart starts here,
at exactly the position
of the second magazine.
This is one of the last
photographs ever taken
of the super battleship.
Above it, a column
of smoke rises three
miles into the sky.
The result of that final
catastrophic explosion.
-When Yamato blew up, there
was a huge mushroom cloud, a
preview of the mushroom clouds
that would very soon appear
over Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
bringing the
Pacific War to an end.
NARRATOR: Kazushi Hiro
was assigned to another ship
after his training on Yamato.
Now aged 94, he still
prays for his many crew
mates who died that day.
KAZUSHI: Dozens of
the names of my friends are
inscribed on this cenotaph.
I come here to visit their
graves once a week since
I have time and I'm alive.
NARRATOR: Japan's
top-secret battleship was
destined for the sea floor.
Not because of its kamikaze
mission, but its secret
weapons were rendered useless
by the changing nature of war.
-The sinking of
the Yamato was the last
gasp of the battleship.
It demonstrated that unless
you had air cover, you were
very vulnerable to torpedo
attack and therefore the
age of the battleship was
certainly coming to an end.
NARRATOR: The men who
sacrifice themselves on board
Yamato are inspired by an
astonishing event.
From the age of
samurai warriors.
As the China Seas continue
to drain away, extraordinary
evidence emerges,
about an enduring
maritime mystery.
How did the mightiest
invasion fleet of ancient
times vanish without a trace?
-It was one of the biggest
disasters in the history
of maritime warfare.
NARRATOR: Imari Bay, Kyushu.
The southernmost of
Japan's four main islands.
700 years ago, warriors of
the Mongol empire launch
an invasion of Japan here.
Under orders from one
of the most powerful
leaders of all time...
Emperor Kublai Khan.
The Emperor is the
grandson of Genghis Khan,
the legendary warrior who
united the nomadic hordes
of the Mongolian plains.
Now leading one of the
largest armies in history,
Kublai Khan continues
to expand the
Mongol empire through China.
He establishes
the city of Beijing
and grows fantastically rich
from a vast trade network.
His power over life
and death stretches from
Europe to the China Seas.
But the Great Khan
isn't satisfied.
-Kublai Khan was expanding
the Mongol empire eastwards.
He made himself Emperor
of China, he made Korea
into a vassal state,
and now it was Japan's turn.
NARRATOR: Standing
against the Khan are the
samurai warlords of Japan.
And in 1281, he
decides to reckon with
them once and for all.
He constructs the largest
fleet ever seen and
sends it across the sea.
JAMES: Imagine what it
must have felt like if you
were a Japanese standing
on the shores there?
All of a sudden, what you're
seeing is a wall of ships
as far as your eye can see.
-The Mongol fleet was huge,
getting on for 4,000 vessels
of various shapes and sizes.
It was probably
the biggest amphibious
operation before the
Normandy D-Day
landings in 1944.
NARRATOR: The samurais
fight bravely, and
try to hold the line,
but are hopelessly
outnumbered.
As the first wave of
invaders battles on shore,
more are approaching
from the sea.
But then, something
astonishing happens.
The massive fleet of Mongol
ships mysteriously vanishes.
-The loss of Kublai Khan's
invasion fleet, getting
on for 4,000 ships,
was one of the biggest
disasters in the history
of maritime warfare.
NARRATOR: So, what happened?
Japanese scribes credit
divine intervention.
Historians, archaeologists,
and divers scour the seabed
and pore over the archives.
But fail to discover
a single shipwreck.
Until now.
NARRATOR: Fascinated with the
legend of Kublai Khan's fleet,
maritime archaeologist
Kenzo Hayashida has
spent years searching for it.
KENZO: I have committed myself
to the survey since 1988,
so for more than 30 years.
NARRATOR: Kenzo is inspired
by an ancient Japanese
record of the invasion.
It's only brought out
on very rare occasions.
NARRATOR: The scroll clearly
shows hand to hand combat.
And even the missing ships.
But it makes no mention of
divine intervention plunging
the fleet to the sea floor.
But under the waters of Imari
Bay there are some clues.
A Mongol helmet, buckles,
even an ancient comb.
And then, this.
A bronze seal inscribed
with a date, 1277.
Struck just four years before
the Mongol invasion and it
carries the mark of a soldier,
a very important soldier.
IKUHIRO: It was an official
seal of a company commander
in the Mongolian army,
and the discovery became
important evidence.
NARRATOR: It's
the strongest proof yet of
the Mongol invasion fleet.
JAMES: In terms of a smoking
gun in archaeology, it doesn't
get much better than that.
NARRATOR: Inspired
by the find, Kenzo
takes to the water.
Layers of thick mud make
searching here very difficult.
But when he starts dredging
the sea floor itself, he
makes his first breakthrough.
-What we found were mostly
goods carried on the ships.
For example, weapons,
armor and pots to put food in.
NARRATOR: But still,
where are all the ships?
Kenzo and his team need
to find a way to peer
even deeper into the mud.
And for that, they
turn to technology.
NARRATOR: Based on this data,
draining the coast of
southern Japan slowly reveals
something spectacular.
First, some fragments
of broken timbers.
But then, blowing away
centuries of silt...
exposes the original
seabed of 1281.
And there, resting on top
of it, visible for the
first time in 700 years,
the extraordinary tangled
remains of Kublai Khan's
lost invasion fleet.
NARRATOR: And the drained
seabed reveals something else.
-And there, much like you
would see from a crash
site of an aircraft,
you see fragments of
ships lying everywhere.
NARRATOR: Amongst the
debris, weapons, pots,
even the bones of
Mongol warriors.
-It's as if you took
hundreds of ships and put
them through a blender.
NARRATOR: What could wreak
such havoc on an entire fleet?
Is this evidence of
the divine intervention
of samurai legend?
The answers lie in the
thousands of wood fragments
scattered across the seafloor.
Using the data from
the sonar scan, like a
giant 3D jigsaw puzzle,
it's possible to rebuild
Kublai Khan's warships,
and it's not what the
archaeologists expect.
Most of these ships
were doomed before
they even set sail.
ERIC: Kublai Khan had great
problems mobilizing a fleet.
There were Korean
vessels, but many of
them were just coastal.
There were Chinese
vessels, but many of them
were just river craft.
They weren't very suitable
for an oceanic invasion.
NARRATOR: Many of the ships
lack one critical feature.
A deep keel.
Meaning they are unstable and
easily swamped in rough seas.
What's more,
they're poorly built.
NARRATOR: But shoddy
construction doesn't
account for the extent
of the devastation.
A clue to
what happened lies 700
miles away, in Tokyo.
This is Japan's
Meteorological Agency.
Its records only
go back to the 1950s,
but in that time,
a clear weather
pattern has emerged.
HIROSHI: Japan is in the
north west Pacific area,
where typhoons develop most
frequently in the world.
NARRATOR: Each year, at
least a dozen typhoons bear
down on the Japanese coast.
One thing about the
Mongol fleet is clear...
it arrives in
late summer of 1281,
in time for typhoon season.
Where wind speeds can
reach 190 miles per hour,
generating deadly
waves 40 feet tall.
A wind the Japanese
call, kamikaze.
JAMES:
Kame for God,
Kaze for wind,
creates a powerful
legend of the Divine
Wind that saved Japan,
or the kamikaze.
NARRATOR: Japan will
evoke the Divine Wind
again on the brink of
defeat in World War II.
It doesn't stop US forces
then, but 700 years earlier,
the original kamikaze smashes
Kublai Khan's poorly
built fleet to pieces.
-Most of the damage would
be due to the typhoon.
NARRATOR: The greatest
army of the age...
powerless in the face
of nature's fury.
As the China Seas
continue to drain away, the
receding water reveals another
maritime mystery just off
the coast of Vietnam, a
vast jumble of shipwrecks
spanning 2,000 years.
What made this stretch
of water one of the most
dangerous in history?
And what extraordinary
treasures lie buried
on the sea floor?
IAN: First time in history,
eyes are looking at this.
NARRATOR: The Cham
Islands, off Vietnam.
Part of a region
known as the coast
that sank 1,000 ships.
Not the ships of
fierce invaders, but
ambitious traders.
Clues to centuries of
bustling commerce are still
found on the sea floor here.
For as long as anyone can
remember, local divers have
been making intriguing finds.
Porcelain and ceramics,
hundreds of years old.
TRAN XA: According to
archaeologists, the object
is considered antique.
It belongs to around the
14th or 15th century.
NARRATOR: In local shops,
recovered ceramics sell for
hundreds of dollars apiece.
Where do these
treasures come from?
And why are they strewn
across the harbor floor?
A research team is scanning
the harbor with the
latest sonar technology.
IAN: If you go to
a beautiful place like
the Mediterranean,
you've got
40 meters visibility.
Here we can be down to half
a meter so this time, the
government has allowed us to
bring remote sensing
equipment, and we're
using side-scan sonar.
First time in history
eyes are looking at this.
NARRATOR: Just minutes
into the search, grainy
images of what could be
wreck sites appear
on the screen.
-Guys, come and
have a look at this.
This is really interesting.
NARRATOR: The team
dives for a closer look.
And in the
gloom, a field of broken
ceramics slowly emerges.
They scour a total area of
four square miles and what
they find is extraordinary.
-Ooh, hello baby.
NARRATOR: After careful
analysis of the survey data...
it's now possible
to drain the sea
from the Cham Islands.
And remove layers of
sand and mud to reveal
an astounding sight.
A treasure trove of 15th
century Chinese ceramics.
Cups, bowls, plates,
still stacked in neat
rows after 600 years.
Scattered all around are
more wrecks, as many as 30.
-We're talking 2,000
odd years at least of wrecks
that we'll actually have
under the surface here.
NARRATOR: Why so many wrecks?
And why so many
loads of porcelain?
The answer lies in the Cham
Islands' unique position,
at the eastern
end of the world's
greatest trade route,
the Maritime Silk Road.
Stretching from Asia to
the Middle East through to
Constantinople and Europe.
For 1,000 years,
this oceanic superhighway
connects princes and popes,
kingdoms and empires.
JAMES: It thrived because
you had silks, you had spices,
but you also had porcelain.
Chinese porcelains
are beautiful,
they're magnificent.
-It's simply down to the
clays the Chinese had.
They had very,
very white clays and
it was unlike anything
anybody had seen before.
NARRATOR: The drained
harbor of the Cham Islands
reveals yet more
spectacular sights.
A United Nations
of shipwrecks.
A Spanish galleon.
A Chinese junk,
an Arabian dhow.
But why are so many ships
wrecked in such a small area?
-I like to call this
the parking lot theory
because most car accidents
happen when you're
trying to get in and
out of the parking lot,
and the same thing
holds true for harbors.
You have a cluster of ships
trying to get in, get out,
and if the wind changes,
you're blown right up onto
the rocks of the beach.
NARRATOR: Drawn by the
lure of porcelain and silk,
the crews of these ships
all hoped to
make their fortune.
But instead,
they paid the ultimate
price on this congested
and storm-lashed coast.
Today, the China Seas are
still a major trade route,
but it's not porcelain
that's transported
across the seas, it's data.
What was once the Great
Silk Highway, is now an
Information Superhighway.
And just like
the Maritime Silk Road,
this Data Highway
is beset with dangers.
What are the deep-sea
risks to the Worldwide Web?
GRAHAM: In this particular
case, effectively
it was a perfect storm.
NARRATOR: Our love of
the internet knows no bounds,
with demand for data doubling
every two years.
And the biggest
gigabyte gluttons?
Social media and video.
Lots of video.
GRAHAM: Currently, there
are four million views of
YouTube videos per minute.
That is an enormous amount of
data that's being consumed.
NARRATOR: Add to that
the trillions of dollars
in electronic funds
that shuttle between
corporations and banks...
and it amounts to an
astonishing 3.4 petabits
of data that we gobble up,
every 60 seconds.
-And for those who don't
know what a petabit
is, ten to the 15 zeros.
NARRATOR: All that data
has to be stored somewhere,
which we call the cloud.
But data doesn't
travel up into the sky.
It's actually transported
deep below the sea.
Draining all the oceans
reveals the million-mile
network that connects
the Worldwide Web.
Where data shoots
across the sea floor
at the speed of light,
inside vast
arteries of cables.
JAYNE: We talk
about the cloud.
The reality is 98% of
the internet runs over fiber
optic cables under the ocean.
NARRATOR: One of the
busiest and most important
stretches of the internet
is here under the China Seas,
in the Luzon Strait, between
Taiwan and the Philippines.
And like all undersea cables,
this Data Superhighway
is vulnerable to attack.
From the ocean's most
fearsome predator,
biting onto cables...
to entanglements with
even bigger creatures.
This footage shows what
happens when a humpback whale
becomes wrapped in a loose
data cable off the
coast of Norway.
The fire department manages
to free the whale, but
it means cutting the cable,
plunging parts of Scandinavia
into an offline abyss.
To reduce the dangers,
engineers take a course not
open to ancient mariners,
burying precious cables
deep below the seabed.
This delicate work
is performed by a flotilla of
specialized engineering ships,
which slowly unwind enormous
drums of cable that will
stretch for thousands of miles
across the oceans.
But the crucial work,
happens deep below the waves.
Draining the water from
above the ocean bed exposes
the giant machines that
build the Worldwide Web.
A plough, the size of a house,
crawls along the sea floor.
High pressure water
jets help carve a trench
ten feet deep and the
cable is buried inside it.
In the deepest parts of the
ocean, far beyond the reach
of anchors or even whales,
the engineers lay cables
directly on the seabed.
Draining the deepest canyon of
the Luzon Strait reveals the
main data artery that connects
Asia and the West,
19 cables that shuttle
trillions of gigabytes of
data between businesses,
governments, universities,
and stock markets,
all of them lying
exposed and vulnerable.
Graham Evans is
the Managing Director of
a company that plans where
cables are threaded
across the globe's oceans.
-It's not just a flat,
featureless seabed.
Some of it is extremely rugged
and we're having to maneuver
around some of these features.
NARRATOR: His job is to
find the shortest route
from point A to point B.
But avoiding underwater
obstacles mean that
cables converge to what's
known as a Choke Point.
Like the Luzon Strait
and its 19 cables
linking east and west.
-Why is it a choke point?
There are no alternative
routes when you're trying
to go from Asia to the
United States,
or Asia to Japan.
NARRATOR: On December 26, 2006,
the choke point becomes choked.
-It was certainly
a, a date that the
industry won't forget.
NARRATOR: At 8:26 pm,
a deep rumble shakes the
seabed of the China Seas,
an earthquake with
a magnitude of 7.1.
In Taiwan, buildings
collapse, two people are
killed, and dozens injured.
But that's not the end
of the devastation.
In the deep canyon of
the Luzon Strait, there's a
second stage to the quake.
A massive underwater
landslide.
-In this particular case,
it was a, effectively
it was a perfect storm.
There had been this huge
build up of sediment at
the head of this canyon,
and it didn't need
much to trigger it.
NARRATOR: Directly in
its path, the data cables
on the canyon floor.
-So, if you're
on the floor of the canyon,
what you would see is this
billowing mass of black mud.
It pretty well took out
every single cable that went
between southeast Asia and
the United States.
NARRATOR: The internet
shuts down and within
minutes millions feel the
pain in their wallets.
-No submarine cables, no cash.
NARRATOR: ATMs stop working.
Stock trading halts.
Billions of dollars of
transactions freeze.
Corporations and banks
are paralyzed on both
sides of the Pacific.
-In this particular case,
there was never so many
simultaneous cable breaks
that had such a devastating
impact on the world's
ability to use the internet.
NARRATOR:
After some frantic work,
data is rerouted via
other networks,
eventually stemming the chaos.
But it takes three
months to fully repair
all the broken lines.
This cable crew
and others like them,
will be busy
for decades to come as the
demand for data continues
to surge, driven by the
booming economies of Asia.
To compete, or collaborate,
trade or invade?
These twin human
instincts continue to
define the China Seas.
Draining the waters here
reveals a turbulent past.
Exposes the truth behind
a mysterious legend.
Celebrates the wonder
of the Worldwide Web.
And whatever's to come in
the next digital revolution.
Captioned by Cotter
Captioning Services.